über diese pose zu heiraten und daran
hindern jetzt geht und herzlich über und
zu meinem heutigen video is s t zusammen
mit sebastian mein bruder und ich bin
auf eine youtube kacke zur letzten
helfen der folge auch die wir beiden
reagiert haben gestoßen letztens kam es
auch bei weiteren dreh die soweit ich
weiß wie youtube kacke reaktion größe
gehen raus waren die beiden wir haben
ein anderes video gefunden was erst 28
aufrufe hat und ich bin sagen wir gucken
mal rein
youtube kacke hilft mir alina ist ein
goldschmied sport macht die kleinen
kreis change schaue aber zwei abonnenten
seit einem jahr verlobt sie wollen in
drei monaten heiraten
alina sieht sich mit ihrer besten
freundin vivien im brautmoden laden um
ihr verlobter ist selbstverständlich wie
ihr verlobter alina ist
selbstverständlich hier verläuft und
welche maßnahmen haben wir gar nicht
herausgefunden
ja ich war mir so zu reden
den kostenpunkt je teurer desto teurer
auch gar keinen sinn da wir noch was
david berger entweder rechts hat nichts
gemacht
die rechte tiefe und wie gefällt das
nicht so also ein schöner rücken hab es
nicht aber ist die relativ einfach
gestrickt aber trotzdem sehr lustig es
kommt einfach immer das teil wo das was
raus geküsst wenn die nicht sagen damit
es nicht raus geschnitten wenn ihre zahl
werde die stelle weggekürzt sozial aktiv
kleiner die nicht zum tragen können sie
suchen kann auch für mich nicht in frage
kommt so schien als ob du wirst so stolz
auf diese nicht willst du schön aussehen
10 euro
du gibst du wie bekloppt warum
nicht dass ich den mann vom anderen
genommen wurde
sie kennt ihre herangehensweise gute für
die kleinen besucher nicht entfernen
aber ist das war sie nicht nur clubs
geht du hast die eltern 80 80 prozent
der hochzeiten kosten zwischen vier und
sieben euro das meiste dieses geldes
geben die für das hochzeitskleid die
braucht zeit die crowd leid und clyde
ihrer gäste aus
[Gelächter]
kostenpunkt darüber welche hilfsmittel
mathematiker das hochzeitskleid die
hochzeitskleid die frau kleid und clyde
ihrer gäste aus
[Gelächter]
sie selbst sind total egal
die hochzeitskleid die hochzeitskleid
muss man vergleiche mit ihrem wunsch
nach einem hochzeitspaar 10.000 euro
sprang für lina diesen rahmen bereits
komplett über diese große zu heiraten
der gesichtsausdruck und fest daran
hindern
ja ich will und ich bin noch mal hier
weil ich fragen wollten vielleicht zehn
euro liegen könnte
lila ist mir die situation sogar
vorstellen
die eltern hassen die frau nicht
übertrieben und wollen nicht dass ich
weniger kindern nicht sind dann würde so
die können daran glaubst du denn wir
nehmen die 10.000 hosentasche hast du
nur ein bisschen durch es geht um die
zehn euro
wer das geld nicht geben dürfe
das ist so als hätte man so das gesamte
originalvideo genommen hätte so ein -
was so alles umgekehrt natürlich können
wir das geld mich hier raus das video
hat mir nicht hielt mir nicht alle
glücklich sie ist die richtige frau für
dich du bist jetzt nicht und verliebt
und oder nicht ihr kennt mich aber wir
wollen nicht leute werden das video hat
noch ein bisschen kürzer weil es schon
spät